[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et je sais si je vous envoie s'emballe
vous allez jouer au bout de la rue
[Musique]
je dois je dire merci je vous ai envoyés
sans gbagbo vous allez jouer plus loin
[Musique]
où
c'est pas bientôt fini ce boucan bas on
va jouer devant
[Musique]
alors quoi non non monsieur je tu
n'auras
[Musique]
et c'est pour moi c'est joli bouquet toi
je n'arrive pas à dormir et vous
consoler en versant des fleurs toujours
délicieusement poète seul chez moi ça si
lors de continuer tu lui balança toute
l'eau sur le coin de la figure de ma
part sur le coin c'est parfait mais
julien si les mots qu'on va continuer à
faire du boucan tout créera de ma part
également qu'est-ce que je crierai à ce
que tu voudras je te fais confiance pour
une justesse moi je vais dormir
notre chère amie annie n'a vu la beauté
la mienne elle le fera t-elle le plaisir
de se montrer alors tout à l'heure je
met au piano
alors je ne peux me rendre et à ne
jamais arriver chez vous sans vous
trouvez en train de dormir je prends mon
service au journal à 8h30 j'ai besoin de
me reposer moi je vois pas pourquoi je
me retiendrais je te baise au froid ce
n'est pas que je reconnaisse et
hautement les vertus du sommeil certes
comme d'autres je sais apprécier en
artiste de ce délicieux
d'engourdissement qui suit la fatigue et
prépare l'oubli nos préoccupations mais
chez vous le sommeil d'une obsession une
maladie un vice
une religion vous passez la moitié de
votre vie à dormir et l'autre à tâcher
de rester éveillé c'est un corps
[Musique]
ça c'est gentil ça c'est moins gentil je
ne voudrais pas vous gêner dans l'emploi
de vos facultés maîtresse mais vous
voyez enfin la grâce d'une part mais
l'apport de votre chambre
lorsque je viens distraire d'après cette
étude par mon gazouiller délicat ce
geste vulgaire des renseignements
précieux flatteur votre à caractère vous
préférez le sommeil aux idées générales
il vous n'avez aucun respect pour
l'amitié
je me sens tellement important que
l'amitié des combien salutaire
lorsqu elle coûtait d'un individu gorner
en quoi leurs oeufs le destin place un
esprit tendre et cultivez vous fermez
votre porte
je me dois de rendre eux mêmes eaux et
je me permettrait de satisfaire à mon
penchant naturel pour le dessin les
courbes sont toujours d'une rare
délicatesse mais la difficulté
commençons ligne droite
ah oui ça l'est la ligne droite c'est un
travail je crois qu'on a sonné je vais
ouvrir au pourquoi cache pas ouvrir plus
de 112 tat délicieuse année c'est pas
moi non plus mais montrez que vous êtes
bien celle 8
[Applaudissements]
il va venir tout de suite
enfin s'il veut bien car pour tout vous
dire en ce moment ils d'eau et pour lui
c'est pas un jeu je vous prie de me
croire
asseyez vous vous permettez j'ai lâché
on a un petit travail
l'agent scara m'a dit que l'appartement
était allouée est vrai - monsieur vous
ne pourriez pas faire visiter vous même
oh oh mais bien volontiers monsieur
alors ici voyez-vous en somme vous avez
la pièce à tout faire
on y lit on y danse on y dresse la table
on y vit quoi pas moi je suis konami du
lac en passe
suivez-moi alors là vous avez un peu de
cuisine vous l'avez à ses voeux la un
bout de couloir on avait déjà vu la boue
d'ateliers et là une chance et c'est là
précisément que mon ami le locataire de
laitages d'or en ce moment vous allez
pouvoir jouer un tout petit coup d'oeil
pour ne pas révéler je compterai bien
sûr un petit coup d'oeil suffit
et vous avez fait en quelques secondes
au tour de l'appartement jeudi
appartement en espagne du soleil enfin
pas de 58 ans n'a pas beaucoup de bruit
au quatrième étage évidemment mais il y
a l'ascenseur si vous avez un parking à
- moi je les aime beaucoup et pour tout
vous dire j'y viens tous les jours en
passant évidemment les ducs la mine
je viens tous les jours néanmoins
monsieur il ya une question que je veux
immédiatement mais trop de poids mais si
c'est celle des reprises oui je veux des
ménages environ tous les mois et demi
j'ai épousé une malade pour les
mouvements au bout d'un mois
ma femme ne peut plus dormir dans le
même appartement elle est persuadée que
les voisins du nord
il faut vivre en ville n'a pas envie là
est ce centre au sol alors vous
comprenez pour moi la question d'une
reprise a pour sa part c'est justement
enchantée de vous connaître monsieur je
disais justement à monsieur que pour moi
la question des reprises mais la porte
n'est pas à louer ah non monsieur
s'il dit non c'est lui le locataire
n'est ce pas alors c'est différent
dans ce cas naturellement bien sûr c'est
par la muse et par l'âge le petit
couloir vous êtes venus tu es fou
pourquoi qui t'a dit faire visiter mais
c'est une agence car à dévisser vue qui
va demander d'abord battu comme des
ménages laissait l'agencé carat qui lui
être l'indiqué son appartement comme
vacants et tout le problème dans ma
chambre
ils voulaient tous voir le petit coquin
aux remarques il était très poli je t'ai
pas dit vraiment bonjour bonjour comment
vas tu tu as les romantiques et
intelligente et la plus faible allure
je m'exerce à sera ton portrait c'est un
procédé par lequel je pense arriver à
des résultats intéressants
j'ai remarqué que le pilat d'instinct de
sens de la perspective
les cours viennent très bien mais les
difficultés commencent aux lignes
droites prendre la pose tu as du temps à
perdre
oui ça j'ai tout mon temps et s'il vient
pas ici s'en va on perd tout de même
allé prendre la pose donc voilà j'ai un
coup de patte de retailles étonnant tu
vas voir il faut pas oublier que c'est
pendant les pauses ce genre que se font
les aveux important que se nouent les
intrigues amoureuses tu sais que ta
qu'un mot à dire
elle côtoie show racing show j'ai
précisément à la voix de faire avant
tout une passion et bien ton article de
ce matin pourquoi ne pas le dire il est
carrément brevets tient à ne pas voir
assez dormi il ya des fautes de goût
ouais nous sommes énormément ils frisent
le ridicule prend la paix cool que je
t'écoute presse tu prends pas la porte
puisque tu m'accordes quelques
attentions
je voudrais une fois de plus de mettre
en garde contre ce genre ceux de
spirituel que tu a adopté dans cette
interview parue hier plusieurs quelque
chose de charmant avec ses petites
chanteuses
elle est pleine de talent juin prend la
porte je vais te dire une chose
tu critiques c'est facile ça ne va pas
te pas foutu de prendre un stylo et
découvert des lignes sur n'importe quoi
un choix écrivain je voudrais savoir ce
que tu es bah tu vois que j'ai un crayon
et jedessine
et au moment où je me sens inspirée du
préfet à prendre la pose au haut du 2
août un physique étonnant en plus quel
journaliste de grande classe ton
portrait aura forcément un jour de laval
et tu refuses tu me coupe l'herbe sous
le pied puis donc ça reste calme un
moment ça ne fait rien que je lis par
hasard à ça m'ennuie parce que pour
dessiner le journal j'aurai à tracer des
lignes droites fait un journal rond dès
mercredi
mieux c'est drôle année doit être là
qu'est ce qu'elle fait tout noir d'amour
non j'ai faim tu pense à elle tu penses
à ton article où es tu penses à rien et
tu as faim bien qu'il ait parfois tôt
génique jeu tu abordes tu n'as plus dans
le peler le sens de la perspective
annoncée
j'ai des fourmis a tué neuf ans tu sais
tu as choisi le métier rêve éveillé et
tudor debout tu penses à rien tu as bu
ou quoi ou ici y'a pas de danger il dont
je devrais le faire en art et ceci tout
à l'heure un monsieur vient visiter de
l'appartement qui a jamais été à l'om tu
te contentes de détromper
ça lui demander la moindre explication
sans même après son départ en chercher
une toi même affaire abah voilà il ya
dans paris une agence
sion qui donne ton adresse et tu t'en
moques ça toute la journée
tu vas avoir un défilé de gens qui vont
me demander de visite et qu'il faudra
recevoir et envoyer moi en plus je
chercherai à savoir comment cette agence
a pu apprendre que je quittais mon
appartement alors qu'il n'a jamais été
question
mais tout ça est pertinent louis au lieu
de cela tu la faune sans aucun rapport
challenger daf et la cuisine
alors je téléphone non tu prends la
nouvelle pourquoi pas pour chercher le
numéro encore pertinent qu'est ce qui
t'arrive ont jailli du ta faute d'un
coup la mer eh ben où est-il je ne suis
que l'ami moi je viens quand passe ou
est-ce qu'il s'est foutu encore celui-là
ne le regarde pas comme ça mais il était
là à midi
ben oui il a dû en avoir mais il doit
pas être allé chercher le cirque l'eau
tu vois bien [ __ ] dans ta champions au
cabinet oc&c and i tunes passent mon
matos est son cadeau que tu passeras ma
chaussure contre
je l'allumé reperdu val d'oise pourquoi
l'at on est là parce que notre numéro
est pas sorti l'annuaire c'est l'inversé
il a dû sortir mais j'ai perdu quand
même tu as remarqué cette news je dirais
soulèvent mais vous coucher le disque
j'espère bien que ça viendra un jeu non
non c'est mon calme oui et je leur mets
dans sa poule mais c'est pas une raison
pour prendre un bon jour pour le monde
chaque année mon amour je meurs de faim
aux longs cheveux jets de peinture
formidable en peau de quoi que ce soit
si vous la vie sans j'adore les clubs
parce que nous avons les mêmes pieds le
bund depuis une heure et aux questions
de têtu et banane ça va on voit si on
veut lui il est là mais on n'y peut rien
ne tient pas trop pleurer qu'est mal au
dos bien joué a dit ça y est elle te
suit tous à poil et les conversations
vont devenir gay il a réussi mercredi à
placer pour y est c'est à cause de la
corde aval on émettra au panthéon c'est
un arbre fruitier ne sera qu elle joue
6h30 où tu m'en diras lock outés vous
n'avez pas recommencer votre sûr que
chaque fois que vous êtes ensemble tu
devrais être feria qu'avec toi que je
suis sérieuse quand vous commencez comme
ça j'ai leur me suis pas ce genre et qui
a tort année tu nous fais du nez dans
combien de temps avait d'abord je dîne
avec vous dit le chiffrage de jambon me
dis tout de suite je le dis alors j'en
bouffe un jambon frites à jambon ou quoi
jambon la prononçant footeux coupe à toi
victor hugo à la barre les années filent
dans les toits et toi si tu la laisses
pas
surtout pas c'est le massacre des
classes à b un napoléon s'en foutait
complètement
voilà tout l'intérêt non mon ami vient
20 peut-être la meilleure eau il est
ravissant matin dominique les effets des
gens aux demi-teintes pas en rouge
vous trouvez ça fin on le lui rend allez
mon pantalon c'est pas la peine de le
pousser à mon nom mais vous êtes
vraiment débile side furieux
d'amis dit je veux mettre au piano ou
non respecté que j'aurais trouvé le
numéro qui allait falloir le canon java
je sais pas quoi faire qu'est-ce que je
peux faire j'sais pas quoi c'est tout
genre j'avais tout seul besoin de ça
fait mal ce pas dans le sens de la
longueur
il a retrouvé la nuit lui qu'il avait
cachée oui je reconnais que c'était
idiot parce qu'il avait une adresse à
chercher d'urgence eau
c'est vrai que t'es pas au courant
figure toi tout à leurs recherches aux
consommateurs figure toi plutôt elle
s'appelle carre à carre à une histoire
de dames une histoire d' agences de
notation un monsieur est venu visiter
l'appartement et il a dit qu'il était
envoyé par agence car alors nous on va
dire lui faisait visiter
moi je peux pas savoir la journée non
mais après ça qu'est ce que tu aurais
fait annie il pense à rester là t'aurais
pas cherché à savoir pourquoi cette
agence d'année ce faux renseignement une
blague comme les entrées non tu crois
que c'est beaucoup plus intelligent il
sait tous les jours c'est petit billet
non ma boîte aux lettres des petits bio
et d'amour il ya plus d'une semaine que
tous les jours je trouve dans la boîte
une enveloppe sans adresse et sans
timbre donc laissé par ferdinand aubade
à mâcon nous deux ce bon joueur quoi à
madame attend sa jeunesse quand même
quoi obama qu'aux beaux jours ça y est
la phrase rouge des simples à fait par
hasard mais vraiment c'est la france
obtient la séduction est aujourd'hui se
voit or sans signature évidemment
lisible oui t'as pas la moindre idée
attention parce que fou de foot voix de
la chance car à mon dieu elle être une
élève non au rival doit avoir une
adresse mesures urgentes à chercher
oui ça passe à cuba un air pas à cuda
cores carraz
krikor a alors chers chacun à musset et
vous dérange et surtout pas pour moi non
nous réglons additifs alors c'est moi le
satyre c'est pas mon écriture
si c'est tout ce que tu as comme il y a
et pourquoi ça sera moi bateau était
idiot va laisser brûler et une en retour
dominique message en ce qu'il faut
chercher un but d'armand gens mais tu
les entends de munich
c'est moi qui lui ai écrit l'histoire
paraît dans sa boîte aux lettres j'en
rêve voilà mes regards deux cas la
question le moment trouvé messager par
jalousie
il s'agit de la vérité c'est pas moi on
sort ça c'est inouï
il ya huit jours que l'on voit c'est
d'être à annie je viens tous les jours
c'est seulement aujourd'hui vous en
parler et depuis une semaine
vous êtes persuadé que c'est d'être
viennent de moi c'est moi pas su
persuader moi et toi tu penses quoi marc
déry toi tu pourras de marca député
alain coûte ça fait une heure que je
cherche un numéro
ça presse pas mais qu'est ce qui te
prend il me prend que j'ai horreur de
ces faux situation il m'est très
désagréable de penser que dans quelle
importance je te le demande ou écoute
entre nous
ou c'est pas toi et c'est sans intérêt
ou c'est tout et je vois pas pourquoi
tous par là dessus de 6 avant tu as pas
besoin de l'écrire ça pour que je le
sache qui me l'a dit toutes les fois de
ne me n'était pas là mais je vais voir
alors là il se plaît ma tête elle te
suis tu vas donner le plus j'avais prévu
de quoi
jared et qu'elle ne viendrait plus forte
que toi et elle te mettrai en boîte a
nommé pas en boîte
tellement je ne sais pas où j'ai la tête
merci pour les magnifiques fleurs de thé
m'a envoyé moi où elles tombent plus
haut tas du lait payés horriblement mais
on offre des fleurs on en a froid non
plus des mises dans l'autre vaisselle
pour les concerts étaient roses rouges
sublime il y en a hélas 10 mais restent
excellents comme aux roses rouges ça
fait de même un joli bouquet magnifique
tu seras me lui montrer vraiment les
miennes prochaine au plus tard sur moi
pas faux comment veux tu que je les ai
jamais la moindre fleurs je suis
sérieusement annie alors là cinq minutes
de repos blague à part je sais que ce
temps va pas des fleurs tous les jours
non mais ce matin et là je ne ris pas
jeter commandé dix roses rouges se paie
n'ont jamais tu les as pas alors là je
comprends pas parce que pour une fois je
j'avais commandé qu'on les apporte avant
4h et pourquoi 4 en revanche jarry
tu vois il avait rien dit il était là à
parler de tout et de rien il maman venue
des pleureuses me remerciez pas je
plaisante elle même si je trouve ton
ironie déplacer des fleurs pour sera
peut-être jamais mais qu'il avait
commandé coutu se fermer mais
quelquefois les fournisseurs qui
comprennent pas une adresse
ouais alors ça arrivera plus à celui là
c'est sans importance
chaput son ambiance était au faubourg
saint-honoré à droite julien j'ai
l'impression que tombe sur un bac avec
elle dominy je vais te dire un secret je
vais pas envoyer de fleurs non plus la
rente ou bleu des anges que vous n'êtes
pas client avec vos histoires grand
n'importe quoi il dit dont elle tu n'as
pas eu commencent à réagir a dit quelle
heure est il c'est fin à ses principales
si jo tu parles
allez tu sais pour les fleurs vient de
me dire que c'est une blague
les a pas commandé ça tu peux être sûr
de rien
polémique pour une fois de me rendre
dans le jeune et tu prends tu vois on
est avec toi
alors la fieec sa chair tu deviens un
type dangereux
enfin l instant il vient de me dire
qu'il faisait marcher maintenir meurt à
russell sont belles je tape pas les
faire un jour mais reconnaît de moins
que lorsque je peux les choses
maintenant je vais te mettre en chasse
et surtout quand même battu dit qu'on va
les fleurs on croit
après ça que dix études qui les a pas
commandé ça là on prend encore
maintenant et faire la rive
je trouve ça idiot moi c'est agaçant
c'est comme ça pour tous d'autant plus
vrai de dominique que c'est pas lui qui
les a envoyés au fleurissement par la
gaillarde
j'ai pas de veine on n'y avait pas de
carte de visite bon alors c'est toi oui
ou non mais tu vois bien que non le
fleurissement parnasse je t'avais déjà
là je te les mieux nous faut pour ça de
noël qu'est-ce que ça profite à plus dur
ça exprès ou pas au tournoi il s'éveille
louis ont dit non ami tu penses wassa
moratoire pour moi pour moi c'est le
monsieur qui met des gentillesses dans
ta boîte au bon ça suffit comme ça
allait année le dîner je suis pressé
mots
[Musique]
petit bout viennent à vous petit village
cantonaux dimanche petits bouquets ronds
chauds verte mois
d'autres se penchent battue et
programmes
le petit bouquet tout temps le rendez
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
furieux tue pas furieux je trouve ça à
ce moment moi batouala demi-soeur que tu
crèves tout à fait les se dire les
écoutes je déteste être en équilibre
j'allais y voir clair tu comprends
attendez toujours sur un pied je vois
pas pourquoi le fait d'être sur un pied
t'empêche de voir clair voilà voilà bah
j'ai horreur de ça ces plaisanteries qui
montre continuellement dès qu'il est
quelque part on est comme assis sur des
aiguilles ah ouais il faudra alors de
rue grunner encore des places maintenant
quand la corde savoir qu'il envoie des
fleurs ou qui met des petits billets
tant dans la boîte aux lettres ça ça te
regarde seulement moi j'aime pas avoir
en face de moi des gens qui se paie
votre tête et encore plus quand vous
vous y mettez tous les deux je suis sûr
tomber dans tous les pièges non jeu
puisque je me vois si violemment attaqué
annie je te fais juge du débat mon cher
dominique tu es un garçon délicieux pour
la petite amie de piges une si grande
amitié ne vous laisse pas prouvé en vous
offrant ce magnifique piano à queue
geste vraiment désintéressé puisque deux
neveux
je suis seul à savoir si les belges et
les carottes je m'arrête pas seulement
des pêcheurs toi parce que je viens de
te dire quand jade effet juge du départ
il convient donc que tu ne sois pas à la
cuisine le pendant que le deet est pas
sa poursuite à la salle à manger tu
entends année l'autonomie alors
dépêche-toi de revenir parce que d'ici
quelques secondes je vois le moment où
je n'aurai plus rien à dire à part que
oui la voix leur sera bien là la juge
enchaînait bon cher de mini-jeux qui
sait donc que si tu exerces avec une
sincérité indubitable la profession de
journaliste reporter tulle exercera
continue to me passionne
l'aca j'ose espérer il ya deux sortes de
journalistes l'individu subtil est
éveillé et l'individu confiant et molas
or c'est assez deuxième catégorie que tu
as le malheur département enlevez-moi
sanaa
vu de sardines et tulle apathique dans
l'esprit prend l'habitude du sommet
parce que tu m'as d'une petite vie bien
tranquille entre annie est au journal il
va nous reprocher de vivre
tranquillement il s'est passé cet après
midi même trois faits apparemment anodin
mais très important pour toi
premièrement un monsieur vient visiter
ton appartement jamais été alloués moi
j'aurais cherché la peau de cette visite
bon deuxièmement annie pour la septième
fois de la semaine reçoit une
déclaration à sa boîte aux lettres
moi je n'ai eu de cesse d'avoir surpris
le coupable en plus on rez de chaussée
de cette maison il ya une garçonnière
il ya dans au moins un amant dans la
maison simple suggestion les
m'intéresserait de savoir si c'est pas
lui qui doit être caché dans la boîte
aux lettres non le jury da pour l'apport
en europe et refuse à sa polaire
troisième mystère les fleurs bon alors
ça là bas tu cherches rien tu dors
par contre si dans deux minutes au
téléphone que les magasins du printemps
sont a enfin vu sa crédulité rarissime
tu pourras comme un fou sur les lieux du
sinistre quitte à ne trouver aucune
flamme et aucun pompier je vais vous
dire ce que tu attends moi j'aimerais
aussi que des guise as comment du verbe
et de 8,6 gagné en finesse alors là moi
je vais te dire une chose j'aimerais
j'aimerais assez de voir comprendre mais
plaisanterie je voudrais que tu te de
miss un peu en biais de notre cher petit
existants ont bien je voudrais que tu ne
te fâche à spa quand j'arrache dans
l'obscurité ton pantalon et même que tu
as là ce jusqu'à trouver ça plaisant et
c'est ça que j'appelle que m en biais
oui au nom de l'aigu angles aigus tu
présentes toujours aux choses toute la
surface si tu te mettais en bière elle
viserait à tutu gagnerait en
compréhension en légèreté
c'est ta méthode ce qui fait que plus à
cette situation est délicate plus au
team rouge bien
je connais ça on n'appelle jamais les
choses par leur nom un gag fais moi un
gag attend bien oui c'est drôle c'est
drôle on n'est pas à l'avancé après
qu'avant mais quelle recette de grand et
foot tout ça ça t'amuse peut-être mais
pas moi et je vais répondre logiquement
à des attaques multiples et des
plaisance premièrement si on me
téléphonait que le printemps brûle ça ne
pourrait être que du journal et par
conséquent je me précipiterai en effet
quand as tu es petite histoire il se
peut que je ne sois pas assez subtil
pour les comprendre seulement moi je
fais mieux je les devine mais je me fie
à mon instinct les fleurs c'est toi qui
les envoyaient les billets dans la boîte
aux lettres c'est toi le locataire c'est
une erreur d'adressent dont je me fous
mais dans la confession
allô oui c'est moi l'agencé carat oui en
effet il ya trois quarts d'heure environ
comment dites-vous 1
eh bien non ce monsieur était mal
renseigné c'est une erreur annulé c'est
ça on voit mal à c'est lui qui avait
donné notre adresse à lagence et c'est
lui d'une telle visite d'état est rare
d'un stade
voilà pourquoi ils étaient si contents
tout à l'heure ils savaient très bien
que monsieur allait venir
il savait aussi que l'appartement
n'était pas à louer et il avait de cesse
de me faire découvrir que l'auteur de
cette superbe plaisanterie je te lui tu
ne comprendra jamais mon ami le sens
profond de mes gestes les plus futiles
l'aurait ça doit être un autre locataire
au monde j avais tu viens dîner blaise
mais oui mais tu m'avais dit qu'il avait
oublié complètement oublié je suis
désolée surtout oublié de te dire que
dominique était de service de nuit
bonnet à 7h tu fais bien d'arriver quand
même blais puisque la situation tourner
à l'aigre
il va justement sous les rayons une
chose de plus à un moment où moi je me
fasse trop de quoi s'agit-il
non non terminés et bien et toute
l'année puisque vous avez fini dîner
vous n'attendiez pomme je vais rentrer
chez moi
seulement la bagarre était gentil il est
gentil avait fait part et réparer ma
base gratuite par hasard l'atelier
annabi aujourd'hui il a toujours que
j'en tire le bien-être et la suite l'a
dit a dit ware fumée fleurs ou une fois
je n'avais pas de quart mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez des roses rouges arrivent
les mbour [ __ ] qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est toi oui mais pourquoi avec la nuit
avait expliqué deuxième erreur d'un stop
ça suffit comme ça beaucoup n'ont donc
tu es là tu paies ta gueule tu rigoles
halo qui monsieur quoi ah ouais et nanti
des pages vous le passez c'est pour toi
ce trafic alors ouais quoi
non moi tu parles c'est court mais merci
les galeries lafayette brûle
les galeries lafayette brûler ça va mais
c'est la vérité les galeries lafayette
breuil qui est ce qu a téléphoné à son
ami à moi qui savais que j'étais ici par
été formidable ça comme une coïncidence
si nous les tubes bien julien tu me
prends vraiment pour un demeuré
mais ces vérités sa répartie ton service
mon vieux tu te dis que les garder la 5e
rue le sommes un peu tu vas nous arroser
au mur alors ça tu peux être sûr
attendus pour toi moi je file à lisbourg
mais là demain les galeries lafayette
brûle sans rancune
papon
[Applaudissements]
allo
vous l'aimez pas c'est monsieur bears
ont fait
alos sétois berre dis moi ici c'est vrai
non non non on venait de me le dire mais
j'étais pas sur robin tu penches ses
cours d'accor a mis les galeries
lafayette brûle page paris c'est encore
lui julia
[Applaudissements]
vous ont pas trop de bruit dominique non
encore c'est vrai on va du cni rentrer
en général à 4 heures du matin dans
l'après midi on voit plus d'honneur
heureusement que tu as tes reliure pour
t'occuper se seraient moyennement gay
pour toi s'il dort dans la journée s'il
reprend là pendant la nuit
hu a pu te suis habitué d'abord il
travaille de nuit qu'une semaine sur
deux puits cette semaine on s'arrange je
sors un peu plus et on finit bien par se
retrouver au journal ça dépend
quelquefois je me suis né mais julien
quelquefois on arrive chacun de son côté
on se retrouve tous à minuit dans un
café bar tu te souviens d'ailleurs tête
avec une soirée we did on voit plus toi
tu fais la noce de ton côté
oignies si tu savais plaisant toujours
très belle robe là tu seras avec moi
c'est toujours la même chose on ne me
prend jamais au sérieux si tu savais
comme ernest m'a fait souffrir
je t'en avais parlé d' ernest au nom tu
veux rire non l'aviateur le champion de
vol à voile
alors c'est fini tu sais c'était affreux
tu te rappelles il était marié
figure toi que sa femme a décacheté une
de mes lettres lorsqu'il était parti
survoler le mont blanc tu te rappelle
qu'il est allé faire des vols sur le
mont blanc alors naturellement il ya une
scène mais moi j'ai reçu cette lettre la
regarde je l' ai toujours sur moi ou il
m'a dit tu vas voir comme cette offre
n'est pas la peine de lasser par coeur
il m'a dit tout ça c'est très gentil
mais c'est plaisant tri a assez duré ça
te fait rire non je t'assure que je te
comprends très bien
cette plaisanterie si tu m'avais vue
j'ai d'abord pleuré pendant tout un
après midi je n'ai pas mangé deux jours
n'est ce pas cet affreux il y avait eu
ni moins que ça durait et remarques bien
que jamais rien ne s'était passé entre
nous mais ça fait rien il était si
gentil quand il descendait de son
planeur il y avait une façon de me dire
bonjour moi quand il était là où j'avais
toujours eu peur atroce comme tu penses
regarde je sais que ça c'est un petit
morceau de son planeur j'avais pris un
jour au bord du net avaient été raflés
comment j'ai aussi cette capsule tu vois
elle ne me quitte jamais c'est celle
d'une bouteille d'eau minérale qu'on
avait vus ensemble dans un café
tu vois tu ris mais non c'est pas ton
histoire qui me fait rire blaise
victoire mais ton petit morceau de
planeurs de titres à malley ta bouteille
d'eau minérale
mais je ne la porterai plus longtemps
alors dans tout à l'heure je vais voir
airness moment où tu vas bien raison te
réjouir mais ça ne sera pas gay ce n'est
pas un replâtrage c'est même le
contraire
cette rupture définitive je vais lui
rendre tout ça en petits morceaux
d'abord à emma capsule oui mais pourquoi
parce qu'il est passage à la gare saint
lazare
ben alors il l'a fait savoir au nom je
les appelais par les journaux vous semez
tout lui rendre j'ai raison n'est ce pas
ça lui montrera ce que c'est que l'amour
on remarque bien que je ne lui en veux
pas et ça n'impressionne dubois tuerie
le nom blaise assure que je te comprends
très bien nous c'est un peu pour cela je
ne sors pas avec vous justement vous
aimez beaucoup rire dominique jullien et
toi êtes heureux vous passiez votre
temps vous faire des blagues à vous
amuser
voilà bon bah je vais partir maintenant
c'est l'heure de tra prenant part à
17h32 tu as quelque chose à faire avant
au nom ernest n'arrive qu'à 5 heures
c'est bien reste encore un peu de me
dérange pas au maintien si tu veux venir
prendre le thé après parce qu'il fera
plaisir aux tu sais nous sommes
oui tu reviendras tu seras triste il
faut pas rester là dessus allez on
viendra te connais mais sans lui aura
peut-être de mimi le cas de tous les
phares avant et oise à 3 le plus grand
bien
c'est dominique kidjo mais non est ce
que tu penses de dominique pourquoi mais
j'aime beaucoup david icna oui c'est
pour ça que pose cette question à nice
pourquoi tu te méfies jeunes ans et sept
gardes nature elle qu'en parlant comme
on le fait là je te demande que tu
penses de dominique julien dray est
amoureuse de juin
excuse moi j'arrive parce que je
m'attendais vraiment pas ça se demande
ce que tu penses de dominique équipe
devant toi je suis heureuse de julien
excuse moi eh bien je te réponds que
j'aime beaucoup dominique mais je ne
fais pas que te dire on trouve que c'est
un garçon il est plein de vie de santé
l'a vu ces jours derniers non non je
n'ai plus vu depuis le soir de la bague
de l' incendie pas l'autre soir et
julien julien non plus non je veux dire
qu'est ce que tu penses de lui enfin
julien m'amuse où il est ironique il va
venir nuit ben non on n'a pas vu depuis
une semaine on sait pas ce qu'il fait
son téléphone répond pas c'est bizarre
d'ailleurs y'a jamais fait ça tu ne m'en
veux d'avoir été un discret tout à
l'heure mais pas du tout
tu sais un dominique et moi on a pas de
secret j'étais amoureux de julia je
dirais et puis c'est tout bien sûr on a
toute façon le problème se pose pas si
on était plus tous les trois ça irait
plus bien sûr vous avez de la chance
ab oui sans parler c'est notre petit
donjon romillon je t'en prie
c'est un homme qui voit comme elle me
connaît bien et moi je tapoter rouge tu
vois détachement doit apporter sa bague
ah oui mais je les rencontrais justement
il en rapporte l on est montés ensemble
avantage de te rappelles tu mettais
bague parce que des émotions comme celle
de l'autre soir heureusement moi j'ai eu
les galeries ont fait ça a fait
diversion avec ce nom n'a pas aidé non
plus de mettre ses bijoux sans bijoux
plus exactement avec des cachets
d'aspirine et ben j'étais déjà dit que
ça va on en a déjà assez parlé trouve
pas c'est bien d'ailleurs c'est un sujet
triste et moi le sud est pas possible
moi je répare client ne vous dérangez
pas moi tu n'es pas gay alors parce
qu'il est à un tournant de tels cas
quelqu'un va entre temps mais je veux
absolument qu'ils relisent ses premiers
tout à 9 et puis toi baise pas encore
des pétales sur les poules on pourrait
comprendre aux jets merci tu à l'heure
exacte de mini ouais il est à la seconde
près exactement mercredi en tête
merci écoute eu la folie ce problème il
n'est juste avant de me confier que
s'ils n'ouvrent pas plus souvent c'est
parce qu'on est trop gay pour lui on est
comme tout le monde mais lui non il est
encore en plein d'amis jamais il est n
est ce pas la gare saint-lazare rompre
définitivement avec son adversaire
oh là là tu vas ourak c'est un pauvre
type faut toujours qu'ils cherchent la
catastrophe lui la minute pathétique à
cette rupture à la gare c'est bien lui
ça tu vois le monsieur qui va rompre
avec quelqu'un qui n'a jamais pris au
sérieux une seconde c'est bien pour ça
que des revenus d'épargné qui te
plaisanterie je voudrais qu'il change un
peu il est gentil mais les ridicules si
j'avais su qu'il partait pour ça au
contraire je leur ai parlé on n'a pas
été d'être midinettes à ce point là
cette maladie qu'ils attendent tout au
sérieux
écoute je voudrais qui s'allège un peu
tu porte pas de capsules dans ses poches
qui n'est pas les larmes aux yeux chaque
fois qu'un avion passe un peu d'aisance
quoi il sait s'accrocher pour n'importe
quoi
il sera toujours malheureux avec ce
système là il offre à la vie toute sa
surface alors forcément il est un
monsieur
tiens propos et notre chère ville farine
puis y'a pas de nouvelles pourquoi tu
dis à propos
oui tu as dit à propos oui pourquoi tu
l'as dit ambroise tu m'aimes je supporte
très bien est ce que tu es aveugle et
quoi devant moi quoi je dis est ce que
tu es aveugle et à main pas du tout non
non non
aujourd'hui puisque tu me vois comme je
suis aimerait y suis pas différent et
gayheart voie royale a fait remarquer tu
te demande pas pourquoi support parce
que tu as bien dormi bon il t'a pas
semblé que julien est allé un peu fort
l'autre soit vous rêve tu as trouvé
aussi à moi j'étais furieux armand j'ai
vu depuis qu'a été constamment furieux m
eh bien c'est fini tu t'en moques qu'est
ce tu fais des comptes a fini mon paquet
oui et je tiens à te signalé la chose
c'est fini ben oui je veux dire que je
n'attache plus aucune importance à ces
paroles mais c'est ce que je viens de
décider tout à l'heure en me réveillant
et c'est ce qui me rend à mag était
naturel tu comprends julien cherche
constamment à me mettre en contradiction
avec moi même il veut me transformer
d'un an
je suis pas quelqu'un quand on semble
comme ça moi je ne suis pas un champ
d'expérience pour un petit rigolo je me
rebiffe
j'ai ma personnalité bon ben là je peux
faire ce que je veux quand je veux car
tu seras une chose mon amour c'est que
contrairement aux apparences je suis
linverse d'une moule et que la nature ma
doué d'un sens critique qui vaut
largement celui de notre cher ami
je tombe est oui je t'en met évidemment
que s'accomplisse au dominique comment
fait-il remarquer ça n'a rien à voir et
qualité de jeu pour lui mais depuis ces
quelques jours les plus menus moi je
dois dire il n'a pas manqué j'ajouterais
même que grâce à l'absence de cet
individu sertic et 10 seulement
je suis en train de retrouver toutes mes
facultés ardente et généreuse
je viens pas méchante
une expérience tu assiste en ce moment à
ce phénomène psychologique
je m'épanouis ouais je suis comme une
fleur qui s'ouvre mon coco ce lien dès
qu'il est là il crée une atmosphère
inquiète empoisonné néfaste à l'éclosion
de mon génie naturel content qu'on le
voit plus si je veux la mer par exemple
il est la personne ne l'a caché quand je
demande leur tout la vie au lieu de
répondre mercredi ce qui est à la longue
un peu lassant moyennement drôles et
parfaitement idiot parce que j'étais gay
et quand j'ai aimé une opinion je sais
que je n'en aurai pas la critique
systématique
[Musique]
mais n'empêche que je trouve le silence
de juin complètement absurde
tu ne sais même plus ce nom vient du
tout il est peut-être tombé dans les
flammes notoire on l'a dit en contrant
[Musique]
parfaitement juste sur ce combat sûr
c'est pas moi je vais sortir amendes en
cas d'orage il dit
[Musique]
oui les jolies pianiste tu reviens pour
noter la star tiens je parie que c'est
lui je suis seul je vais l'être le faire
mademoiselle s'apprêtait à sortir
allez je te présente perdu à mes
camarades du journal absenté perdu
t'excuses il t'excuses d'autant plus
volontiers que s'il est venu jusqu'ici
c'est qu'il a quelque chose à me dire et
que vous allez partout à tout à l'heure
alors maintenant taman sinon j'ai
entendu dire que tu fumes et merci tu as
raison ça fait du bien aux branches
je te dérange pas pas du tout tu vas
peut-être pour m'interviewer et non
dommage
enfin oui non tu as raison de te
répondre car je suis un sujet qui en
vaut la peine
eh bien mon parfum favori c'est l'heure
bleue pour madame je n'emploie que le
rouge écarlate
pour lui s'il uniquement le mascara
l'eau et je m'habille et ça je te le
dire exclusivement chez mes parents
six jeunes l'automobile j'adore
l'automobile si j'aime lamination
j'adore l'aviation tu devrais peut-être
plutôt du feu toi oui toi je te refuse
rien et si tu as encore à me poser deux
ou trois de ces questions passionnantes
qui constituent le fond de nos
interviews je te répondrai avec le même
plaisir de tous ça a l'air d'aller toi
ça va je me réveille alors tu comprends
je manifeste mon contentement à la
nature c'est de la belle pourquoi ce
surnom lui est ou non c'est toi de gérer
ça parce que je te vois comptant sans sa
vague rose ennuis ce n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde
alors la paire lui jetant tout de suite
tu as un type épatant
je vois pas pourquoi toujours et les
martyrs ni pourquoi tu te diminuerait
parce que je
y a pas bien longtemps je pensais à toi
elle est un bonhomme qu'il faut secouer
ah oui tu mens nenê est beaucoup plus en
cinq mois est en principe ce n'est pas à
moi te dire ça mais tu vois je saute sur
l'occasion
tu manque un peu de mer situé ténue
samsa égal comme tu as du talent c'est
l'avant mais tu mangane si je comprenais
wish d'orgueil
je suis un rêveur voilà la vérité or tu
as choisi le métier d'homme éveillé
voilà ce qu'il faut dire non la vérité
mon dieu sait que je suis revenu de pas
mal de choses
peut-être parce que je suis plus ancien
que toi tout simplement
et j'espère que toi tu n'en sera jamais
la voiture je n'attends rien de la vie
encore moins de notre métier et dans ma
vie à moi il n'y a que deux choses
simone que tu connais un charmant et un
petit oiseau
si toi aujourd'hui mais j'ai un petit
oiseau que j'ai dressé et là tout le
temps à table ils sont sûrement vers il
vient manger dans la main c'est si nous
perdions cet oiseau si ma mémoire
seule tragédie si seulement je ne vois
pas d'un jour ou deux boîtes tupperware
je ne me sens pas à mon aise
il y couche sur mon lit c'est mieux
qu'un enfant il est intelligent il est
enfin pour moi je te dis c'est parce que
tout je ne demande pas grand chose
ouais bah c'est justement ce hacker
l'avant si tu ne peux pas quitter simone
et ton petit oiseau 24 heures évidemment
tu peux pas non plus aussi saisir toutes
les chances
je ne sais pas les enquêtes les voyages
ça ne tend pas non je m'en fous qui
comprend tous les impôts est exactement
bon alors vous voilà ce qui se passe et
il hier j'ai eu un long entretien les
villes à villars que c'est super
seulement un rédacteur en chef c'est
aussi un type intelligent bien commun
ouais voilà ville armes à feu appelé et
il m'a proposé une enquête
oui il s'agit d'un déplacement de trois
semaines et d'une enquête sur l'esprit
de la jeunesse dans l'espagne de
nouvelles surtout oui eh bien c'est à
toi que je viens d'offrir
quoi demander à villars un peu de temps
pour réfléchir et si je te propose la
nuit si je me désiste
je suis sûr que sera désigné mais moi tu
comprends mon attitude je te dise m'en
moque je ne demande rien et je n'espère
rien or cette enquête là c'est quelque
chose fait intelligemment
elle peut être pour un jeune un lac tout
premier ordre
j'ai pensé à toi voilà l écoute je te
remercie c'est vraiment très très chic
de tapas je suis très touchée mais je
vais recommencer at engueuler pourquoi
tu m'apportes ça et pour te faire
plaisir
et toi je te répète ça ne m'intéresse
pas non c'est un peu que tu avais pas si
bonnes et on canaris toutefois quelque
chose dans la vie
non mais oui tu t'endors ne refuse pas
une chose pareille je sais pas moi on
réfléchit même pas alors tu acceptes moi
je suis là ce moment que le vrai il faut
que j'en parle à bali tu n'as pas de
canaris toit en attendant bien sûr et
année compte pas dans les décisions
d'ailleurs l'enfant
écoute je ne peux pas te demander une
réponse immédiate
je vois que tu as l'air d'hésiter tu as
peut-être des raisons personnelles je
n'ai pas à connaître c'est à dire écoute
je dois donner une réponse mois à
villars demain matin a dit s'il a
réfléchi à part la personne au journal
bien entendu et voici mon numéro de
téléphone je te le donne parce qu'en ce
moment je ne suis pas de service au même
sort que toi tu aideras canapé chez moi
j'y serai eric simmons et mon oiseau lra
je le ferais cogner du bec sur
l'écouteur défilé commun si tu lui
parles je te signale qu'ils répondent
aux noms de cécile quoi oui
c'est d'une jeune fille il s'appelle
cécile alors attendu attendu mauvais le
[Applaudissements]
non bâti en espagne il commença membres
étaient tous d'abord cassé c'est tout
juste et ciani se foutait pas douala
tout à l'heure et lui la raison de
canaris mais voilà voilà j'étais de
bonne humeur il a fallu qu'il arrive
avec son histoire
on n'a pas besoin de rigoler je vais te
dire une chose juin je commence à en
avoir plein de doutes je fais ce qui me
plaît tu comprends si je veux pas dans
l'espagne je réponds l'espagne se sont
pas tes petit sourire en coin qui vous
feront changer d'avis je fais ce qui me
plaît tu comprends tu n'as rien à voir
dans ma décision
il ya un quart d'heure j'étais
parfaitement bien sans toi alors pour
lui à 1
et si ça ne convient pas car à prendre
la porte je suis aussi navré pour toi
année car je sais que c'est ton jeu
favori de payer ma tête avec lui mais
voilà je trouve que ça super d'ailleurs
je te réveilles toi oui oui c'est vrai
j'ai pas encore comment restaurer pour
ne ris pas tu sais tu n'es pas le seul à
pouvoir imaginer des blagues
tu vas voir
allo ac toi d'où tu sors en 3d morts
comme par hasard mystère moi je croyais
qu'il était tombé dans les flammes
l'autre soir annie oui elle va en très
bon bon d'accord total à quoi je
voudrais peut voir écrire un compte
rendu de la 110 toi mon article étaient
légion je peux lui casser la gueule
après si on discutera quand il sera en
direct dans le d une terre encore tu
veux soumettre deux billets pour que ça
glisse
oui voilà qu'est ce que c'est d'ailleurs
furieux moi pas du tout abattu te vois
pas je suis je me vois où tu te vois un
je me sors je me sens pas furieux coûte
ne m'appelle plus ton choix j'aurais dû
beaucoup son petit nom gentil c'est trop
gentille et ses palais ne vais pas les
gazettes montée du même année je n'ai
pas envie de rigoler alors tu vois quoi
qui était pas content c'est ton ami
quitte à porter de mauvaises nouvelles
n'ont rien ouais enfin bon on peut pas
le dire
voici quelque chose à t'apprendre je
viens de passer mon correspondant quoi
monsieur kima des billets doux dans ma
boîte aux lettres qui s le locataire
d'alors transpole ça te fait rire toi la
trappe est justement celui d'aujourd'hui
pièce mais ce qui t'a dit gerry c'est
tout cette nouvelle je fasse ça coûte
je vais tout de même pas une machine
d'ailleurs il a été très charmant il m'a
dit je savais bien vous le prendriez
comme ça et pas autrement dit ça y est
j'ai fait connaissance
bah oui on se revoir peut-être tiens
justement il va vite apprendre je t'ai
demain quoi
oui demain of un petit 5 à 7 cents non
tu te fous de moi
les pas du tout nos mimiques et je t'ai
pas dit plus important il est très riche
tu sais il a une ottomanisme alors enfin
tu vois pas tant que ça peut être
intéressant d'avoir l'avis de la ville
ocre ça simplifie encore les charges
moi je suis un petit peu gentil avec lui
lui une zone à très peu d'argent parce
qu'il est très gentil avec moi et alors
on est tous très heureux
puis les soirs où il est pas libre on
pourra sortir toi et moi on ira dans les
bons petits restaurants offrant la fin
non tu veux que j'aille lui casser la
figure pas dominique tu es complètement
d'abord il est très beau très charmant
et très fort il beaucoup plus fort mais
l'entretien de lenteur un coup d'arrêt
qui rigolaient se fend d'une gifle
[Musique]
aussi on peut pleurer et dis moi
pourquoi tu m'as dit que depuis les
jours tu ne trouvait plus de billets
dans la boîte ça continue et cette
plaisanterie oui pourquoi tu m'as dit le
contraire 1
je me battrai pas pourquoi parce que tu
te mets en colère
mélange ne vous met pas en colère ne
peux pas répondre
alors pourquoi tu m'as dit que depuis
jour tu ne trouvait plus de billets dans
la voix puisqu'il était encore pour te
faire croire que c'était julien
bon bien parfait continent alors
justement là quelques touches noires tu
sois là ou non tu penses qu'à lui avons
présentée évidemment quand on a
évidemment tu penses qu'à lui tout le
regrettes tu malheureuse peut-être oui
justement fait une très bonne chose
je suis malheureuse c'est bon ça oui
mais idiot que je suis
tulle m
oui mais dick tulle m oui tu l aimes aux
familles mixtes adobe intel à l'ust
adore quand est furieux je veux pas
d'embrasser parce que chez nous laisse
moi en deux minutes à cheval magnifique
très intelligent bête comme à l'habitude
comme une mule est jaloux comme elles
l'ont écouté ma main coûte bouge pas je
t'aime j'ai jamais aimé que toi je
t'aime parce que tu as toujours l'air
préoccupé que tout roule des yeux
énormes quand est furieux mais je t'aime
surtout parce que t'es pas julien j'aime
julien parce qu'il se fait rouler des
yeux comme personne se trouvant attends
attends je descends j'ai envie de
t'embrasser
et c'est ça je suis un peu idiot il en
deux minutes tu viens de me faire
marcher comme une fois c'est ça je suis
vraiment de quoi tu m'as bien sûr
oignies
l'orgue rappel la première fois que tu
es venu ici alors la première fois que
je t'ai dis ici je vous aime beaucoup sa
langue ses miasmes un petit air un arrêt
tous les deux je crois que je t'aime
toujours autant
vous dites dont j'ai une idée quoi la
première fois qu un virage no way on y
voit croire que je vienne renforcer soit
un peu à nos drian tiens qu'est ce que
tu feras tu vois pas je vous laisse seul
un moment tu lui dis que je suis folle
de lui tu passes dans la chambre je le
vois mon tour est alors venant tenir à
la scène
bonne idée ou quand il dit ça sur sept
ans au noir je pensais mais alors autre
idée non jure mois que la première fois
que nous le reverrons nous serons en toi
et moi tout le temps complice jurés
jurèrent gérer alors tout à l'heure il
va venir me téléphoner il sera là dans
un monde à lui à les jurés qu'est ce
qu'ils voulaient ton ami tout à l'heure
par l'ubs à quoi non il est venu me
proposer un reportage trois semaines où
ça en espagne tu pars trois semaines
c'est à dire je partirai je pars quoi
pourquoi cette en aurait pas oui m'enfin
ça doit pas compter quoi bref c'est
peut-être important pour toi important
l'espagne tu sais tu es si loin on en a
déjà beaucoup parlé tous les cas moi je
veux pas compter dans cette décision tu
compte pas enfin je veux dire quant à
moi j'ai eu raison a refusé ou est
presque belge doit donner une réponse
définitive ce soir demain parce que je
voulais le mettre au courant mais en
fait j'ai refusé tiens c'est lui
pourquoi son latin oui il m'a dit non
ses nerfs j'essayais macler louvre à
bravo un basique
chère madame boulet vont me permettre
rien n'est plus vulgaire que ce geste
tellement ridicule mais j'ai pensé ne
pas me séparer de ses fleurs afin d'être
sûr qu'il n'arriverait pas de la part
d'un autre et encore voyez vous je
n'arrive pas en être certain mais
c'était ma bravo aux jolies à morel
julien oui je ne sais pas si vous vous
rappelez nous sommes rencontrés un jour
place de la concorde commandes à ce cher
pompiers et là je te parlais à calais
remontée heureusement tout la portée des
fins on va je ne me trompe pas si mamie
ce bouquet entre les mains
les phares mesures de protection
exactement aux oiseaux un fil de fer
barbelé les futurs pratiqués n'ont reçu
sera rien j'ai recommandé qu on les
emprisonne pas ça leur fera plaisir
alors voilà ma prise n'est pas les
oreilles je suis avide explications il y
en a pas 36 j'ai quitté paris le
lendemain du feu enfin le soir même
c'est à dire quand j'étais rentré chez
moi j'avais trouvé un télégramme mon
ancre alfred au plus mal alors j'ai le
plus parti pour nice tout de suite je
sais que vous lever tard le matin je
n'ai pas téléphoné par discrétion
alors il vaut mieux qu'ils savent allant
de l'alfa d' les démos alors sachez
l'udc n'a plus les flots oui le l'iran
on était plein j'ai profité mal à garder
et je pensais bien oui mais voilà
et vous ça frère de taper un cousin oui
et vous savez vous ce à lahti portal 2
bah non il m'a rien décelé la bombe on
va voir alors écoute match n'ont pas dit
lorsque tu es devenu depuis une semaine
mais ça un nouveau triste à d'autres les
grands comment on ne sait pas comment ça
vous histoire
moi j'arrive ici tout ça tout à fait que
ça va amener d'un nul peu en effet grâce
et bappa abcès fourre tout qui leur a
pas dit la vérité c'est peut-être on va
évidemment tu vois tu arrives
elle croit plus rien lamentable tandis
prix mais bon allez annie le thème non
et je vais le papa et moi même fait le
avoué toi à l'opinion bonjour ma flamme
à une crampe
je réfléchis at a l'air coquin tu as
échos comme moi à quoi penses tu à la
façon de faire bouillir no 1
oui je voudrais pas faire ça d'une façon
banale y mettre un peu de personnalité
doit aller tu trouves à il semble comme
ça on disparaît une semaine sans rien
dire exactement une histoire banale au
moins un coup de julien je veux que tu
me dises exactement ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé depuis huit jours
dominique est furieux contre moi alors
je lui ai dit l'autre soit deux ou trois
choses qui ont dû le piqué est arrivé
furieux il te dit que tu es un empêcheur
danser en rond que si j'étais pas là je
serai capable de se débrouiller tout
seul que je là pas besoin de moi pour le
stimuler qu'il est capable de l'activité
débordante
ça c'est la réaction de tous les faibles
des cons et lâche un moment tu sais pas
ce que j'ai fait pour lui moi au moment
où les montées à bloc et furieux contre
moi je vais proposer un reportage
sensationnel et oui je connais bien son
rédacteur en chef
c'est moi qui les persuader de donner
saint dominique mais écoute bien c'est
un camarade à lui qui lui proposera à aa
alors que pensez vous de moi monsieur je
prends la perle des amis arriver à ce
résultat de faire travailler de munich
presque malgré lui c'est pour magnifique
ça n'est ce pas seulement verra t on ils
refusent ils refusent un camarade est
venu le voir tout à l'heure il refuse et
enfin il doit donner une réponse
définitive ce soir ouais alors là ça
devient grave et légère m on dirait que
cette fois c'est lui mais c'est un vol
aller j'y allais j'ai dû faire bouillir
l'eau avec trop de personnalité se passe
quelque chose d'anormal tous aujourd'hui
je fais jouer voilà tantôt
chien
2 - en vitesse je pensais pas pouvoir
parler c'est la sienne mais qu'est ce
qui t'arrive tu va croire que je perds
la terre je ne la perd pas j'ai une
chose fantastique a dit vas-y pour
excuse moi mais on y en a pour quelques
minutes au maximum brésil ou alors voilà
les six jours où tu n'as pas été là et
aujourd'hui même tout ce temps là ça a
été impossible
quoi donc rendant impossible tu vois
aller nerveuse irritable pas moyen de
prononcer son nom sans souffert agonir
d'injures un item long 2
on était fous je te dis tiens tout à
l'heure on parler de toi j'ai vu le
moment où elle fondait en larmes
non je serai peut être que tu es fou
tant que tel je sais très bien que le
peuple ait beaucoup discutent pas nous
séparerons a nié moi j'ai rien à faire
entre vous dans ces conditions je vais
même te dire une chose pour moi ce ne
sera pas un sacrifice
bah oui j'ai pensé à ce que tu m'as dit
une autre joute a raison faut que je me
secoue moi je voulais savez je ne pense
pas assez à ma carrière et je crois que
c'est justement à cause d'année chez
l'ami trop facile entre allen
journalisme en bourgeoise trouvant aussi
je viens d'accepter avec enthousiasme un
reportage qu'on m'a proposé trois
semaines en espagne at a accepté oui
alors je vois puisqu'elle il te plaît et
kate adorent mais ah oui le tas d'or ah
bon alors alors je passe dans la chambre
tu lui diras je suis sorti pour aller
acheter des gâteaux
et ont besoin vous partirez tous les
deux tu n'as comme on va dire
elle est à toi attendu
allez le tpr est écoute moi je parle
sérieusement il a refusé le reportage
on peut donc pas alors suis moi
dominique est en train de devenir un
petit futé l'éditorial aulas et comment
tu sois tranquille bien terminé
m
sous deux mois
si jo a cette fois je suis en retard
excusez moi je t excuse été pincé encore
que ça on le sait déjà servitude vois tu
m'excuses aussi à nîmes soit tranquille
elle s'excuse aussi les entrevues c'est
bien pour eux tu sais avec ernest je
vais tout rendu le bouchon la capsule le
morceau de planeur et sa lettre otites
ou sur le quai de la gare saint-lazare
c'est si facile
il a pris le train de 17 heures 30 de
haut si tu savais comme cet affreux des
adieux sur maquette garde
j'avais un risque à moi alors ton
aviateurs s'est envolé
tu plaisantes d'amis ni qu'ils n'avaient
pas choisi qu'est ce que tu as tu n'as
pas la moindre idée
annie a perdu sa bague non elle a foutu
le camp
quoique n'est pas ça mais qu'est ce que
tu veux mais je veux dire qu'elle est
partie si tous une image te dirai
qu'elle s'est envolé comme temps à 20h à
la quitter quoi seulement mal n'a pas
donné rendez vous à la gare est allé
seul ou plutôt non mais ça c'est le
bouquet elle y est allé avec julien way
sont partis ensemble c'est impossible et
harris a dit le tout fort c'est une
chose qui est assez amusant entendre sam
the repartons pour need julien voilà
c'est une blague
moi je laisse supposer un instant quand
la saône et j'ai cru que c'étaient eux
qui revenait non c'est pas une vague et
ce cas mieux c'est que c'est moi qui les
ai fait partir ensemble oui car à
l'origine avait bien eu le bac seulement
testée mais c'était moi qui l'avais oui
mon vieux j'avais pas cannes et
soudainement à toi tu es fou annick aime
beaucoup dominique je croyais c'est pour
ça que j'ai voulu m'amuser avec julien
il faire croire cannes il aimait c'était
pas très fort je le reconnais ça devait
être anodin tu vois c'est devenu
magistral alors là qu'on noit par hasard
falling blague elle porte
mais même pas c'est elle qui a tout
manigancé
oui je vous laisserai seul un moment tu
lui diras que je suis folle de lui et tu
passeras dans ta chambre
je le verrai à mon tour et on
réapparaissant tu verras la scène je les
ai vus
voilà au courant tu vois aussi le
personnage d'année à henri envoyé en
trouve ça très drôle et puis un beau
jour on fait ce coup là comme une blague
encore il ne faut pas dire ça dominique
mois ernest m'a quitté mais c'est quand
même un être adorable mais si tu veux
que c'est julien qui est un [ __ ] oui
ce n'est pas gentil annonça pas gentil
comme tu dis qu'est ce que tu vas faire
[Musique]
c'est pas
tu as une idée ouais il faut pas
s'affoler
tiens j'ai eu des émotions toi aussi tu
as besoin de te remettre aller à ses
toiles à prend du thé et manger des
gâteaux baitullah moi j'ai autre chose à
les bouffes souffle à l'eau perdue au
pardon vous voulez me le passé valable
s'il n'est pas trop occupé avec son
petit oiseau piniès bouffe bon vieux
bouffe bien je vais dire une chose
dans ces cas là il n'y a qu'une solution
haute mais de bien tu comprends alors ça
glisse j ai même mieux plus les
situations sont graves
plus on gagne en légèreté c'est la
formule du bonheur tu crois et quelle
recette de grâce sa fiche que ferais tu
vois je m'envole à l'eau c'est toi perdu
c'est d'accord j'accepte je pars demain
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est affreux bout ce programme ont été
tués oui mais c'est moi l'assassin
je me suis vite j'ai pas d'alibi
possible excuse moi je ne sais plus ce
que je vois bien mais ça fait rien on
nettoie mon coeur mais toi mais pourquoi
cette mise en scène finisse comme ça
c'est pas toi j'attendais la porte était
ouverte la rue c'est moi qui l'avais
ouverte
j'attends dernier eut un peu fine tu
m'as fait une peur atroce attendait pas
moins de poids est lui aussi aurait été
à foix les noms aliments est sauté sur
l'avant et j'aurais gueulé comme un âne
avec vos fans jamais depuis la mort au
trajet la cour non plus c'est justement
sur ce point que nous opposons au toit
et moi dans ma volonté chagrin n'est pas
pour en parler je suis venu te voir à se
moquer de moi oui pyatt a nié m'a dit tu
étais ici
battu ce don ou à l'aise chez moi mais
qu'est ce que je sache et voilà que l'on
aime téléphone ce matin lundi de venir
ici à 6h en moi je la rive est allé chez
toi enfin moi j'ai cru qu'il était sorti
avant je sais moi jean prat être bâclée
et j'en étais tu es pas pour la recevoir
et parce qu'elle sait chaque fois appelé
soumettre ledit me l'a dit le danger
n'est hélas passé la nuit chez moi
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça hier soir
on est allés au cinéma elle et moi je de
mise en attaque si à une heure elle
rentrait ici n'avaient pas surtout
amélie est venue elle y est toujours oui
tu es toi je cherche ne cherche pas nous
sommes en plein drame
makoko tu me fait un enfant
tuilerie en nombre à pauvreté ne rit pas
julien ce n'est pas drôle tu me prépare
bien en tout cas je tâche alors vas-y
donne un grand coup
dominique est revenu à ou alors la
blessed a raison sur cette grave
il vous est il doit être là roulent peu
dans sa chambre il doit dormir qu'une
apport gardien on arrive aujourd'hui à
jamais dans les chambres quand j'arrive
ici j'appelle deux fois ni deux fois
dominique quand je n'ai pas de réponse
je m'installe et j'attends je vais
arriver j'ai pas eu de réponse
mais il ya peut-être là nous sommes en
pleine tragédie vous c'est bien mon avis
et du plaisant où on explique on extrait
voici ce qui s'est passé à nyon petit
temps 7 mai venu jusqu'ici mais en
réglant son père si elle avait de la
lumière à la fenêtre de sa chambre et
l'a compris que dominique avait dû
rentrer elle a eu peur de quoi pas d'eux
que deux 2 jours c'est pas moins de le
revoir de se trouver en face de lui tout
d'un coup elle est venue coucher points
wii il a téléphoné au journal ce matin
on lui a dit que dominique avait bien dû
rentrer cette nuit et il dort depuis son
voyage adule fatigué avec les fuseaux
horaires y'a qu'a voir d'ailleurs quoi
ne bouge pour les dunes veut pas
retarder cardin du rappeur toi aussi
battu ma foi et enfin papa tu veux un
peu de films ou oui julien encore à peu
près
ne te greespan ça vous donne de l'audace
mais bien sûr alors c est lui qui m'a
fait venir ici pour le corps à corps des
parents gens pensent que je vous répète
depuis le premier jour vous prenez cette
histoire en rien mes et tournera mal
moi j'ai vu dominique ici le chemin de
votre départ et une houle a dit où il
prétendait que dans la vie il faut se
mettre de piet pour que les événements
vous touche moi mais quand j'ai lu la
faire ton pour nice il n'avait pas du
tout l'air d'être de seulement ne sommes
pas partis blaise voilà à nice que dans
ces 24 heures lendemain même une fois le
tour joué à dire dominique partie elle
rendait s'installer ici je sais je sais
seulement tu vois hier soir dès qu'il a
compris que des mythiques et hermione a
eu peur elle n'a pas osé
il a pensé comme moi que dominique
pouvait ne pas la croire vu des nerfs
pauvres
enfin le drame oui ils dansent et me
soutenir oui me dire tout ça pour tuer
fouet ne sais pas c'est moi qui ai
décidé de venir quand j'ai su que tu
étais ici c'est oit de quelques rangs
des noms aussi lorsqu'on entre en jeu on
va se comprendre ce à deux états font
dire qu'en revenant tu me trouveras très
trop nombreux je ne reviendrai pas
c'est si tu reviendras pourquoi vous la
surprise party comment on va faire une
surprise party où cela dit si tu me tues
plaisent ou mais pourquoi de légende du
julien c'est que je ne ris pas mon joli
tu vas même me rendre un grand service
oui ni non oui mais non mais oui mais
non mais oui quoi qu a prise qu'après à
cabris mais non à quoi joue son va-tout
bien compris je n'ai rien compris julien
aucune importance tu fais bien tout ça
viendra pourquoi surprise party fou mais
julien tu te rappelles quand airness
m'acquitter quand ils étaient 6000 sont
avec nous racontera sa totale pourquoi
l'atmosphère sera déjà la rigolade
tu plaisantes en choeur n'en croit rien
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
je m'inquiète aussi pour quoi faire
parce que l'heure est grave
je t'explique de deux choses l'une où
dominique a compris il se met bien lui
aussi
et le drame possible se dénoue en un
quart d'heure de passes gracieuse où il
n'a pas compris comment fera jamais rien
il se met pas de biais alors la hâte au
retour tu trouveras deux cadavres ou 3 a
fait ce qu'il avait compris il ne rentre
à faire et ça mérite jamais jamais à
temps plein ne cherche surtout pas
[Musique]
o o c vous grand garçon je me disais
aussi je pense et moi même vous êtes
seul oui je suis venu en me promenant
par la rue kléber sans doute non par
l'autobus
d'un point de vue c'est surtout un moyen
de locomotion je pense par exemple en ce
moment si je vous disais que cet
appartement me paraît agréable je serais
assez spirituel vous vivez seul je
reviens de voyage à vous dire un bon
voyage voyage utile il m'a semblé qu'on
appelait c'est la crétine deviennent
chrétiens dans la maison à l'étagé en
dessous juste or ces récents son tout
nouveau m'a dit la concierge
je m'appelle julien mois dominique même
si vous pas une amie qui s'appelait ali
elle est plus ici
il m'est arrivé avec elle une aventure
originale est un écrivain pourrez y
trouver une mine le k9 elle est partie
avec un ami à moi au santé ressort c'est
passionnant rapporté moi c'est sûr je ne
pense pas qu'elle remette jamais les
pieds ici vous pensez avoir été dupe
j'ai toutes les raisons de croire j'ai
entendu parler d'elle il paraît qu'elle
n'est pas parti avec un ami à vous et là
elle fait affaire des 24 heures et à
simuler une fugue dans un bus à elle
comme c'est ça j'ai entendu dire que
cette fugue et ce but était de faire
partir vous même je ne sais quel
expédition au bord de laquelle vous
hésitiez l attention adorable
il paraît même que l'ami et dans le
secret que lui même n'avait pas d'autre
but alors c'est une huile et dévouement
qu'on trouve autour de soi la vie vaut
la peine d'être vécue au à ce propos
connaissez-vous les diana co c'est une
famille régnante
japon sont de minuscules insectes réduit
en poudre qu'il faut toujours un peu
dans sa poche sur toute occasion
et voici pourquoi pour ça il faudrait
quelques vieux disques de phonogrammes
je crois qu'ils sont là alors je vous
montrais ça tout de suite
alors vous prenez un peu de poudre dans
votre poche comme ça vous saupoudrez un
premier disque et vous le tout le tracé
voilà vous voyez un deuxième disque
voilà tout cas c'est un troisième disque
que vous saupoudrez up et vous casser
ensuite vous enlevez votre robe de
shanghai est comme ça merci voilà alors
vous prenez encore beaucoup dans votre
poche ont saupoudré la route des champs
vous l'avez c'est tombé à terre alors
j'ai oublié la suit partout tu paieras
cds que je lui en donne l'occasion de
nous revoir et à mistral à votre chère
amie annie pourquoi m'avoir vie calme
est revenu ici le lendemain de mon
départ parce que c'est vrai il n'était
pas ici elle est allée au cinéma avec
moi elle est arrivé en taxi à il me l a
vu la lumière à la fenêtre de sa chambre
elle n'a pas osé monter c'est chez
blaise qu'elle a passé la nuit
j'y vais parce que vous n'êtes pas du
tout les trains convenable
ah qu'il est une chute alors question du
gaz je vais lui dire qu'on avait
retrouvé asphyxié 4 lyon la bouche il
est parti à vous convient pas encaisser
dans ces bois d'ouliat j'étais déjà dit
un jour si vous vous aimez alliés toi je
n'ai rien à faire
le comment pourrais-je dominé ensuivrait
tu ignores toute mon existence nouvelle
j'ai rencontré la femme de ma vie
nous sommes partis en voyage de noces en
italie et je suis arrivée seule issue
tout à l'heure ça la suite 2000 ruse ma
bien aimée ne quitte jamais une semaine
nous sommes inséparables et tu vois là
elle a trouvé le moyen de nous rejoindre
elle même tu comprends elle est là où ma
voix je j'ai du style pas mon âme ou
quatre il ya quatre mois d'amour est pas
qu une simple mais nous étions nous
sommes à paris du monde seule dans les
rues
- l'amour c'était pour voir grand ami à
moi je ne vous ai tous folk avec toi
catherine au capri c'est fini
nous sommes plus seuls simon ammann en
regard
à
[Applaudissements]
son esprit était sous mon charme au jeu
vient de briser mon bonheur de mines et
pourquoi qui oscillait alors que vais-je
devenir maman
voilà on fait bien gentille à nieppe à
venir souvent tu veux bien soin de
minutes je voudrais bien moooh julien tu
proposes place je ne suis pas seul moi
non plus vraiment un ton temps passe et
la crds est il justement seulement l
epal étage en dessous
elle est là dans ma chambre qu'est ce
que tu dis comme unique mais oui je vais
ramener hier avec moi c'est une petite
crétine j'ai trouvé dans l'avion elle
est sans fin mais tu sais que j'ai très
bon coeur je les adopter je la
soignerait comme un enfant aux bâches
comprendre et dont je peux l'avoir cette
pauvre idiote mais bien sûr je peux te
l'a montré n'est pas trop peur une
seconde
mais
à bonn voilà oui évidemment il faut pas
trop la regarder bon aussi ne me suis
attaché qu'au fond de sa nature qui est
essentiellement bon elle parle pas
beaucoup
on peut pas dire qu'elle soit m mais à
peu de choses près aux filles
ah oui son langage courant tu l'as
entendu agen voilà quelque chose comme
ça alors mais elle dit tout avec ses
très sobre moyens elle dit bonjour bien
vos maîtres sympathique ou bien allez
vous en les jours de la semaine sauf
mais tiens tu veux dire les jours de la
semaine pour le monsieur ma petite crête
une la semaine lundi tu vois et c'est ce
qu'elle dit le mieux surtout mercredi tu
as remarqué pauvreté alors tu comprends
ma vieux fait bien sûr bien sûr être
jolies jambes tu as là des jambes
qu'est ce que veut on peut pas tout
avoir voilà ta intention de partir tout
de suite
mais nos bons
bon ben je vais vous laisser un petit
moment ensemble vous tâcherai de trouver
un sujet de conversation surface tu
verras elle a des idées politiques très
arrêtées moi je m'habille j'ai pas
choquant de chambre tient une jolie
cravate
asseyez-vous crétine pratique sans doute
vos parents des crétins généralement que
prennent soin spa vous fumez non non
vous ne devait pas fumer néanmoins la
fumée ne vous dérange pas eau et le feu
elle aime le feu avec les petits os la
prédina jolidon oui elle aime le feu
et moi j'ai un moyen radical pour
éteindre les incendies alors remettre le
feu à sa robe kurde emploiera bon moyen
ça serait même plus drôle ont commencé
par mettre le feu à sa main cette crête
je m'amusais et voyez il ya des jours où
je me sens bada mais ça je veux plus
maintenant je veux parler sérieusement
de crétin à crespin où l'avez-vous
rencontrée à malaga plein d'étrangers
j'étais à l'étranger parisienne c'est
vous jure il nous a parlé de moi se sont
depuis bien certains matins je me trouve
charmant seul c'est assez rare heureuse
j'ai beaucoup de chance même à malaga
vous êtes méchant c'est pas mauvais
garçons n'ont manqué un peu d'aisance
simplement la d'écouté amusez vous en
connaissez plus que moi oui moi j'en ai
un ou deux qui sont pas mal j'ai eu
raison de venir n'est ce pas gamin vous
devriez même partir tout de suite dit si
vous n'êtes plus destiné à vous revoir
les adieux sont toujours pénibles
ce soir ça m'est impossible mais demain
à l'heure du thé vous êtes totalement
libre
quel est votre 9 avenue de messine au
rez-de-chaussée première porte à gauche
ah non je l'expliquerai les actes et de
rien toujours amusant de se connaît
attention aux débris messin dominique
adore que personne et 10 mai son jeu
favori
passé par là le petit couloir vous
accompagne pas à demain
autant je travaille pas comment te
sens-tu je ne ris pas beaucoup c'est un
coup dur est ce que tu es de biais alors
tu vois il me semble que je tourne un
peu tourner pas reste deux billets le
plus possible y'a qu'ça d'vrai je
tournais assagi peut rien mais alors là
tu vas me cogner dessus y'a des chances
à tous attention à toutes ces années
nous broie pas mélanie p entoura seul eh
bien non
aujourd'hui jean princesse aujourd'hui
l'air bonjour je vous attendais c'est le
fils du grand turc le petit pur qu
prince héritier et prince héritier et
figure adjani flottant ou en promenade à
paris il comprend notre belle langue
alors ses études depuis hier lors d'une
conférence de recollement fillon mais
qu'est ce qu'il dit et leurs avions
est ce qu'il ya des éléphants visa tombe
dans l'escalier il a l'air d'aimer les
bagues
mais qu'est ce qu'ils avancent étouffe
telmo fiancé c'est le bonheur d'être à
la vitra plus paris rien ne trouble pas
oui pour cela vous allez vous marier
très vite il arrête ses études mais il a
arrêté aujourd'hui
bon ben ça lui fait toujours un mot à sa
disposition c'est l'amour c'est la vie
c'est le voyage c'est le trouve
tellement on est fillon ne vous dérangez
pas j'ai fait comment s'appelle-t-il
très très difficile a pas lancé en
français il a l'air coquin
c'est un chien s'était encore lankais sa
non traité 1 des éléphants
et si vous voulez vous voulez des boules
de gomme ah bon mais alors vous
permettez j'en ai moi quoi des bulldogs
personnes
qu'est ce qui se passe j'ai pas fini de
me faire faire le chemin en a été
sublime
on croit toujours qu'on a trompés ils
t'adorent il a compris il est bien
maintenant à toi tu de gagner ne vous ne
bougez pas aller tourner trois fois 1 3
4 fois en avant trois quatre et tu
enlèves ça dans cinq secondes
qu'est ce que je vais moins de temps
encore prometteuse et déformé où en êtes
vous au moment capital de vidic et
encore après 60 ans t'assois île aux
parfums le premier pas est un nid non
plus faut que ça peut durer longtemps
ça va durer dix secondes encore je
frappais à cette porte si on répond pas
on se donne le bras on s'en va c'est
gagné la vie est belle
si on répond entre et tu partiras tout
seul tu sais que j'aurai encore à faire
tu frappes
allons-y déjà qu'est ce qu'on fait on
s'en va c'est d'espérer déjà scélérate
évite tout commence alors tout va vite
aller vite à leur service ou pas c'est
la mort comme on fouille on fait voulais
me touche c'est pourquoi je joli temps
n'est ce pas
soleil couchant sur la mer ouais c'était
l'époque des gaulois ce temps plus
qu'avec toutes ces inventions en matière
d'électronique
c'était évident c'était normal ça devait
arriver d'ailleurs le tpr je m'assieds
j'adore les situations nettes
on sait où on va pas d'équivoque pas de
demi-mesure limpidité tranquillité
solidité félicité voilà botton ouais je
la trouve pouf am stram gram pic et pic
et colégram bord et bouira d'atteinte
hamstra grimpe au témoin quoi qu'il
cherchait de sucre
il est parti
il ya une pas on dirait
[Musique]
à
coucou bonjour cher c'est julien n'avait
pas été là n'y aura battu un jour
peut-être voulu une victoire aurait pas
si plaisant fait quoi je devrais dire
des choses affreuses prochain on est
sortis comme des anges débrouille pas
mal quand je me mets de billets dire
qu'on pouvait tout cas c'est non tu
imagines la grande scène du 3 le tu vois
le retour du monsieur qui veut pas
comprendre à vieux julien à dieu allait
tout héros style de peinture et en plus
se doivent au village pourquoi tu m'as
parme ac tout à l'heure dans la chambre
parce qu'on était personnes la nsa j'ai
un petit délicat
[Musique]
je passais dans votre quartier l'ange du
tueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs am
stram gram nous aurons le plaisir de
jouer devant vous ce soir et de monsieur
andré roussin de la pmi françaises
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le décor et de roger hart
les costumes de donald k o
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la mise en scène de claude nicaud
avec max bureau
[Applaudissements]
barbara sommaire
bruno balp
[Musique]
jacques ramade
gérard lartigau
[Applaudissements]
elisabeth vénère
[Musique]
je
c'est malin
il est
oui
on m'avait dit
alors
[Musique]